I love these things you missed episodes
they're really fun to make and they're a
great way for me to explore the game
with you guys while I work on bigger
projects in the background anyway like
if you learn something new dislike if
you don't etc etc so there's this shot
in the well if you knock down the rock
but everyone already knows that around
the side though are these irritating
pigs that chase you around the place if
you a grow them they're pretty evil and
I kind of mean that in more than one way
because did you know that they have
around the 5% chance of dropping a
cracked red eye orb I don't know if it's
worth I growing them for that though I'm
sure we all have fond memories of being
chased around majula by these little
bastards so is it worth it it's up to
you while we're in this room you'll
notice this little book sticking out of
the bookcase and it was in Dark Souls 1
as well in the Duke's archives it's a
little bit of an easter egg at this
point so it's a reference to a real book
and you're gonna have to excuse me for
butchering the French language but I
believe it's called Letizia de vivre by
Paul ARCA this name translates to the
desire to live I guess it's kind of an
ironic statement considering how Undead
lose the desire to live although whether
it's ironic or not I guess depends on
the content of the book I would love to
know what it's about French Varda video
fans if you're out there all three of
you you know what to do moving on using
a bonfire aesthetic in majula
adds an extra skeleton to the basement
every time which at New Game+ 10 can get
pretty ridiculous
further within the basement are the
fragments of the Lord vessel which can
lead to all kinds of speculation here's
a picture that was floating around
awhile ago showing the two pieces it's
clear that this is the same thing but
what is the significance of this feel
free to debate in the comments I'll
probably just end up talking about it in
another video as we go deeper into the
mansion we find something else
interesting did you know that if you
kill a boss than his corresponding area
on the map will light up in flame but
that's not all did you also know that if
you use a bonfire aesthetic on a
corresponding boss and kill him in New
Game+ 10 then his flame will turn
I came across a thread on reddit where
people were discussing this and people
were kind of wondering you know what
will happen if we kill all the bosses in
New Game+ 10 what happens if we turn all
the flames blue I think people are still
holding out hope that there's something
in this game that absolutely no one has
discovered yet and it's possible we all
hoped that the pendant would unlock some
secret passageway in Dark Souls 1 and
something along these lines is possible
in Dark Souls 2 but it becomes more and
more unlikely with every passing day
another example of this is the Emerald
Herald in the credits there is credit
given to the voice actor of The Herald
as an adult and the voice actor of The
Herald as a child yet the child Herald
isn't found within the game perhaps
shall be included in some sort of future
dlc we've been through the voice files
of the game already and I don't think
we've found anything on this topic but
you can still hope moving along you
might think that the armor merchant just
sells a limited amount of armor but did
you know that he sells more gear
depending on how many souls you've
traded with him by a thousand souls
worth of armor and he'll sell the elite
Knight and the Royal soldier set by
16000 souls worth of armor with him and
he'll become really cocky transforming
from a little timid man into an arrogant
one and so have we met oh sorry it's
just I've been awfully busy lately he
then sells the alva set which is one of
the better sets in the game and there's
also another secret here if you come to
him with 0 souls while he's in arrogant
prick mode then he'll take pity on you
and he gives you the transparent aura
set for free from shell qua we can get a
bunch of really useful items you'll need
the cat ring to traverse the pit in
majula easily but did you also know that
she gives you a pair of boots that help
with falling damage after you kill the
Rat King it's kind of annoying that she
only gives them to you right after you
really need them but they're not bad
also you get the covetous silver serpent
ring after purchasing 10,000 souls worth
items from millennia and moving on to
another NPC one of my favorites this is
Lenna grassed the blacksmith in majula
his face is identical to the one you
find on the arch stone in Demon Souls
the
one that depicts the king of the borough
is underground there's actually another
reference to demon souls in majula
or I think there is anyway you see this
map in the mansion it's in one of the
Demon Soul cinematic so I swear this
landmass off to the side almost
perfectly matches the map of drangleic
in majula but notice I call these things
references not links to that game from a
law point of view Dark Souls is a
completely different universe to Demon
Souls and this has been pointed out by
the devs multiple times that doesn't
mean you can't think of it as related in
your own head you can keep your own head
Canon but that's just what the devs have
officially said and that's pretty much
it
let me know how many you got out of 10
leave a like if you learned something
new but from this point on this video is
going to be a bit of an update video for
those of you who are interested this is
a chance to look at where we've been and
where we kind of need to go from here
it's almost like traveling to majula
after you beat a boss then warping out
to the next zone you need to conquer you
know it's almost poetic so let's start
with the videos I've made in the past my
prepare to cry series comes to mind
first there are some seriously
heart-wrenching stories in Dark Souls 2
and I bet you missed a bunch of them so
I'm really looking forward to bringing
them to life but the thing is as much as
some of you might want me to I'm not
going to rush them out of the door for
the sake of early views I made the
original prepare to cry about a year
into the life of Dark Souls and while
I'm not going to wait nearly as long as
that to release prepare to cry I'm also
not going to release them until I'm
ready if I do when it's going to be done
right you know another thing that's
worth mentioning is that people don't
actually have a good idea of what's
going on in Dark Souls 2 right now
prepare to cry is about interpretation
of character stories I take the most
likely explanation and I bring it to
life in a logical way if people don't
understand what's going on in Dark Souls
2 then they won't understand my
interpretation and if they don't
understand my interpretation then I'm
going to have to spend a lot of time
explaining it and if I have to actually
explain something too much in prepare to
cry then it's going to be really bad
storytelling so it makes sense for me to
cover speculation first so that's what
I'm going to do prepare to why maybe
still thinking about series names
speaking of which they
last few days I've been working on a
video summing up with the main plot
points in Dark Souls 2 and this is a
gargantuan task and the script for that
video is already about 4000 words long
it took a long time to tie everything
together and to do all the research so
when you don't hear from me for a while
just assume I'm working on something
bigger because not every video can be
made in a day or two and speaking of
bigger projects I'm in something of a
transition period with this channel
right now with all the pledges on
patreon I now have the ability because
of you guys to invest in really big
projects and it has to be bigger than I
originally anticipated you know because
I didn't know how much I was going to
make and one of my main goals with
patreon is to be able to afford more
soul songs so first off that's what I've
been doing i've been painstakingly
trying to find singers songwriters
performers who can bring the souls
universe to life and when you think
about it there aren't that many people
who fit that criteria you know I have to
search for all this talent myself and
it's hard to find the perfect person you
know it's hard to find someone who can
produce the tone somebody who's happy
with the rate I give them somebody who
has the free time and someone willing to
learn about the souls universe and then
once I find that person there's a lot of
emailing back and forth as we hash out
those details so as you can imagine this
is taken up a lot of my time
but I've had a lot of success I have
found two people so far and they're so
good I can't wait to share it with you
so I think part of that is because when
I tell them about this community it's
really hard not to be inspired because
of you guys so I've been busy compiling
assets these past few days things that
tell them about the universe documents
pictures assets videos things that can
guide them when they create a soul song
for us so again just to reiterate when
you don't see a video pop up for a few
days
assume that I'm working on some projects
that will show up later so how many of
you are looking forward to the PC
version I'm Sookie
I can't wait one of the best things
about Dark Souls PC was that video
creators could use cheat engine to
manipulate the camera get really cool
angles and also most importantly walk to
any bonfire from the very start of the
game this saved so much
time and allowed for much better videos
that's another reason I'm not going to
bother making many prepare to cry videos
until PC those videos deserve better
resolution and more polish that I can
give them and the PC version will allow
me to give them that level of polish in
terms of content on the channel right
now I want the next few weeks and maybe
months to be about exploring the game
with you guys that's the theme and story
mode is part of that it's about
exploring the story one step at a time
and the things you miss series is just
about that as well it's about combing
every area for interesting tidbits and
putting those in a focused video that's
fun to watch story mode and things you
missed will probably be expanded to
include more areas in future I realized
that my things but week's episode didn't
really have enough good facts and so
from now on I think I'll only cover
areas where there are seriously some
hidden things as usual this short video
has no irritating ads thanks to the
folks over patreon calm
and I'll catch you guys next time
[Music]